let me just add that according to
our estimates, what is happening in the
Donbas today is genocide, we
hear
that Ukraine is not ready to
join NATO today, we know this and they
immediately say that it will not be accepted tomorrow, but
will be accepted when it is prepared for  this,
but for us it may be too late,
so we want to resolve this issue
now, right now, in the near future
during the negotiation process by
peaceful means, so we proceed from this
and really hope that our
concerns will be
heard and taken seriously by our partners
orion toshiba positions he is safaga to hell
with you something gong zigoton costigan the
general staff writes and autogas from mom
let the nipples spin at the
anti-mage sans mashaihin done in the
beginning from the view to us gosias and
facing them mortars president at em am
c again and a movie about  I’ll say the hoe and I
didn’t give my head for memorabilia
and the containment of Russia is
perceived by us as a direct and
immediate threat  ties of national
security,
which legal agreements are called upon to remove,
but on the basis of the
projects submitted by us, I repeat
the responses we received from the United States and
other NATO members to the proposal for a
security guarantee, in our opinion, do not
meet the three basic
Russian requirements mentioned, there are a number of
considerations that we not only  we do not
mind discussing them in essence at
one time and proposed to our partners
in previous years on issues of
European security on
certain weapons systems, I
mean a medium-range and shorter-range missile of
military transparency, we are ready for
this joint work and further
about we want this  or no, of course
not, which is why we put forward a
proposal for a
negotiation process, the
results of which
should be an agreement on
ensuring frame security for everyone,
including our country, with regard to the
executive authorities,
including the military-political leadership of the
country.  there is nothing to comment on,
a decision was made to partially withdraw troops
for
the State Duma to vote, they think
it is somehow connected with this, of course,
because the deputies of parliament, just
like in any country in Russia, are
guided by public opinion, they are
guided by the opinion of their
voters and they subtly feel it
in this  connections are quite obvious in our
country, the
vast majority of people
sympathize with the
residents of the donbass,
support them and hope that the
situation there will radically change
as far
as how we, as russia, will act
further
according to the plan
and what it will add up from the real
situation on the ground
who can answer that  how it will
shape the real situation for the time being,
it depends not only on us, but we
intend and will strive to
negotiate with our partners on
the issues that we have
raised for their resolution
through diplomatic means